et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec hymnes et sa belle fait de la
consultant en relations internationales
et spécialiste du monde arabe ont jour
et merci d'être en direct avec nous
alors on voit ça deux jours jacques
albert ya eu un effet de choc dans la
péninsule arabique l'absurdité de la
guerre au yémen selon les mots du
ministre libanais de la formation une
phrase qui a été prononcée avant même
son investiture
en tant que ministre de l'information
alors comment est ce que aujourd'hui on
a des jeux qu'elle dort peu un petit peu
rattraper la situation on sait que hier
il a déclaré qu'il n'allait pas
démissionner
oui tout à fait en fait il s'agit d'une
déclaration qui a été faite le 5 août
dernier dans une émission enregistrée
par une chaîne qatarie est là la
déclaration il s'agit pas seulement de
10 mm il s'est exprimé sur pas mal de
dossiers sur le monde arabe notamment le
printemps arabe la question de la syrie
les affaires ce qui se passe en face à
yb ont également le y amène maintenant
le fait qu'il était nommé ministre de
l'information et de la communication au
liban donc ce qui fait que c'est
quelqu'un que représente le gouvernement
libanais moi je trouve que les pays du
golfe vont trouver la libye pour
utiliser un prétexte contre le
gouvernement
libanais maintenant c'est un grand
problème qui s'ajoute à d'autres crises
dans ce pays parce qu'il faut rappeler
quand même que le liban est un pays qui
passe par une crise inédit en matière
d'endettement 130% du pib
libanais s'ajoutant aussi à un taux de
chômage qui est très très élevé qui
avoisine 25% et bien évidemment aussi
une crise politique qui a normalement
connu une certaine ouverture la dernière
période avec la nomination d'un nouveau
gouvernement à la tête najib mikati
normalement acceptée par les par les
pays du golfe mais maintenant on est
face à une nouvelle crise dont
normalement les une crise de l'influencé
étrangère c'est à dire on est à l'arabie
saoudite et les pays du golfe d'un côté
on a le diront d'un autre côté au départ
monsieur georges tartar il voulait
vraiment présenté des excuses par
rapport à ce qui s'était passé mais j'ai
vu qu'il ya aussi les discussions avec
les représentants des instances
chrétienne olivo et aussi la déclaration
de s bona qui a montré un soutien total
aux déclarations de deux ministres
maintenant les retombées de ces deux
sets cette crise et est énorme au plan
économique l'arabie saoudite est le
quatrième partenaire commercial de
l'iran les émirats arabes unis c'est le
deuxième partenaire commercial de l'iran
il faut rappeler aussi qu'il ya deux
cent cinquante mille libanais qui
travaillent dans les pays du golfe et
qui reste et qui risquent d'être
expulsées là maintenant avec ce genre de
déclarations de deux de boycott si
j'allais même d'air de guerre économique
est donc là c'est le peuple libanais qui
qui paie en feront quelque sorte à un
combat à une crise d' influence
régionale mais sur le terrain les pannes
est en tout cas women georges calda et
est accueillie ou plutôt ces mots sont
accueillis d'une manière plutôt
victorieuse on va dire
pour certains et il a dit tout haut ce
que d'autres personnes pensent tout bas
justement concernant cette gare au yémen
oui mais pas tout à fait parce que là la
guerre rouille hamels a commencé depuis
2015 jusqu'aujourd'hui on voit pas qu'il
ya des gagnants et des perdants donc ça
continue jusqu'aujourd'hui en est face à
mn qui ait des visées au moins entre
trois grands clans et a les outils qui
détient la capitale sanaa on a le
gouvernement soi-disant légitime nommé
part à plusieurs instances mais qui
dirige le pays à travers la nomination
des saoudiens parce que c'est un
gouvernement qui hébergea riad et y en a
le conseil de transition de de sud qui
est soutenu par les émirats arabes unis
et qui a aussi un profil on peut dire
d'indépendance par rapport aux autres
plomb yamani donc ce qui fait que c'est
vrai c'est une guerre qui était
déclenchée en 2015 par un coup d'état
des de la part d'eads et des outils mais
jusqu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire
qu'il ya des gagnants et qui a des
perdants il s'agit aussi d'une gageure
politique entre les iraniens et les
saoudiens voilà justement concernant ce
que vous venez de dire est ce que
finalement le liban pourrait se
transformer en un terrain propice à
cette guerre que se mènent actuellement
l'arabie saoudite sunnite donc et les
iraniens qui sont à majorité chiite
là dessus il faut prendre en
considération que le calibre est plus
compliqué parce que le liban était
toujours influencé par les syriens il ya
aussi le risque de guerre avec les
israéliens et donc là maintenant et
aussi les israéliens les les iraniens
plutôt qui soutient le hezbollah d'une
d'une part et on a les saoudiens qui
soutient d'autres d'autres forces
sunnite donc on efface aussi à un cap
faure vue politique très intéressant ça
après je suis vraiment attentif par
rapport aux pourparlers qui se passe
actuellement entre les iraniens et les
et les saoudiens et qu'ils essaient de
partager en quelque sorte l'influencent
géopolitique dans cette dans cette
région et donc on attend donc en fait
d'avoir des résultats de ce genre de
pourparlers c'est là où on peut parler
d'une ouverture d'une crise de la crise
politique au liban merci beaucoup en
tout cas à younes à belfort d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en relations
internationales et spécialiste du monde
arabe